hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be showing uh from the a
second leg of the feed a grand prix that
uh started in belgrade today uh
yesterday was the opening ceremony today
uh were the first rounds and the first
game we're showing is avidit versus
alexei shirov uh neither of them need
any introduction we've seen many of
their games you know the them very well
but as i always like to mention when
someone plays against shiro that it's
probably going to be an incredibly sharp
game and especially in this one
where vidit prepared an incredibly sharp
line for uh sheriff to tackle over the
board so the game is exquisite you guys
will enjoy it uh let's dive straight
into it so that it with the white pieces
opens with e4 uh we have c5 by shear of
knight to f3 d6 and now d4 so just a
normal open sicilian c captures on d for
knight captures and now knight to f6 we
have knight to c3 and a6 the neither of
sicilian is on the board and there are
uh well infinite ways of tackling the
neither of sicilian and the one of the
rare ones is what we see here today and
that is queen to d3 uh we've only
discussed this move uh maybe twice on
this channel and i think um uh once that
magnus played the the other one was a
win uh uh jordan panforest played it
against uh
uh against um
i think granddale you seen the
uh in the tata steel tournament uh last
year uh but it's like i said incredibly
rare but it offers for some very very
exciting play uh the queen can now go
pretty much anywhere on the board you
can easily go go after g7 if the bishop
leaves
the f8 square and it's just a very
tricky move for black to handle because
well you're not used to it so um
what can black do here well the usual
replies knight b to d7 continuing as you
would against pretty much any move that
white plays we want to play b5 bishop to
b7 rook to c bring the knight to c5 so
the usual knight of stuff so here we
have bishop to e2 and now b5 black
continues um uh well in a normal way uh
and here uh there are some games in the
database the reach disposition uh
specifically the one that we've
discussed the jordan forest versus the
grand delus from the tata still where a4
was played uh from forest was able to
win that game but here we have knight
the d5 by viridit and already as of move
eight we have a completely new game with
this very uh very special setup queen on
the three knight on d for knight and d5
and uh well it's black to play what do
you play here uh well you don't want to
capture the knight obviously
sometimes you do because the white
already moved the knife twice and it
seems like if you eliminate white's
knight then you will cost quite some
time but here white would just control
too much space already controlling that
c6 square not something you want to do
so of course shiro just continues
development bishop to b7 and now we
strike against the blacks expansion on
the queen side with a4 now threatening
to win material here so you have to deal
with this and the best way is uh well
almost always the way that we don't want
to go and that is b captures an a4 but
this is such a such a sharp line it
would seem even uh too sharp for shirov
but we will show it because it's super
fun b captures on a4 and now white has a
variety of ideas but uh the the cleanest
one seems to be queen to c4 going after
that knight to c7 check so black would
have to eliminate the knight so white
gets his pawn on d5 now controlling the
c6 square and now we get something like
queen a5 check bishop d2 queen will
capture the pawn here and now queen
captures an a4 and look at this this is
a complete mess even the queen can
capture on g2 let's say queen captures
and g2 white castle's queen side and if
you're not sure about what you're doing
and if you've seen the line for the
first time you do not go into something
like this with black because it's just i
mean look at this
everything is there's no apon there's no
g pawn the rooks are opened the bishops
are out and the black king is stuck in
in the middle of the board
an engine might hold this uh a human
well hard to believe so instead after a4
sheriff continues with knight to c5
makes more sense you attack the queen
you attack the a4 pawn and now video
just plays knight captures on f6 with
check so you mess up black spawn
structure a little g captures on f6 and
now queen to e3 again another move that
if not prepared it's hard that you would
make it because you uh well you block
the development of your own pieces so
it's very hard to play this and what
what happens if just knight captures on
a4 is this a free pawn well if we
capture it uh not really it's uh close
to winning for white because here c4 no
of course you cannot capture because the
knight would hang and once the knight
goes back let's say this you play b4 and
the position is just terrible for black
once the knight moves we're gonna
capture here uh black's entire position
just falls apart so uh here shiro goes
for b captures on a4
and now comes f3 just solidifying in the
center saying i have all the time in the
world to recapture here once i kick the
knight away so no problems there so here
e5 chasing away the knight and now
knight to f5 as the bishop left the c8
square the f5 square is a beautiful
outpost for the knight there is no e
pawn or g pawn to kick it away from
there
but as uh
the case is with anyone who plays the
sicilian defense if you allow them to
push d5 you can be very sure they will
push d5 so here sheriff just plays d5
and now white has to be careful the e4
pawn is under attack and also d4 might
be very very unpleasant if if it uh
comes on the board so e captures on d5
we have queen characters and d5 a nice
developing move for shiro
and now queen back to f2 now the bishop
can be developed to e3 but also it's
such a weird square for the queen this
is uh
everything about this game is just weird
and here sheriff waits no longer he just
uh pushes e4 you could wait with this
you could prepare it a little bit you
could play some like rook to g8 h5 all
good moves but here shiro likes to
attack he pushes e4 right away and now
what can vidi do his knight is all of a
sudden hanging on f5 so he has to move
it does he move it to e3 or g3 uh both
moves have its uh merits uh but uh
knight to e3 comes with tempo so uh he
goes for this queen back to c6 and now
uh video just castles and um uh you
don't really have to worry about e
captures on f3 because once the bishop
recaptures it's not really an ideal
setup for black so here sheriff castle's
queen side
as he also wants a safe king before he
starts attacking but now avidit goes
knight to c4 and uh all of a sudden you
can see the problem with black's
position uh you can see that the knight
has a very easy access to the pieces on
the queen side the bishop can easily
come to f4 uh preventing the king from
reaching safety uh you can never capture
here because bishop just captures an f3
puts more pressure on black's
queen side so what can shiro do here
first he moves the queen queen to e6 and
now he's already threatening e captures
on f3 uh the bishop cannot capture the
knight would hang on c4 so what do you
play here uh if you go bishop to f4
which seems like a really really great
idea now he captures an f3 like we've
said just isn't all that great for white
so instead uh vidit plays the will
the very natural b3 he just defends the
knight and says all right now i'm gonna
play bishop to f4 and then it's going to
be very good for me so here how do you
how do you tackle this uh
instead of b3 also knight to a5 just
going after the bishop was a was a nice
idea but here we have eight captures on
b3 first eliminating one pawn c captures
on b3 and now
even knight captures on b3 and now the
rook is hanging also the bishop is
attacked what can uh what can with it do
here
one way is to just move the rook to b1
but this is extremely complicated i will
just show it because i know how much you
guys enjoy such lines and this is one
big crazy line since the game just
started uh so we might as well
continue in the same spirit so here if
rook to b1 then we get e captures on f3
bishop captures so we give up the knight
on c4 but it's only a temporary
sacrifice and after queen captures here
we play bishop characters on b7 king
captures and now queen f3 check connects
with the knight on b3 that's already
attacked by the rook so after king a7
we're gonna capture on b3 and now okay
listen like bishop c5 check black wants
to get some pieces into the game and now
queen d5 offering a queen trade uh and
now okay uh if you look at the position
black is up two pawns but white of
course will not trade queens here white
will just move the queen or something
and then good luck surviving this uh
position with the king on a7
again it can probably be played with
perfect play black is probably okay here
but uh
uh well it's so hard to go for something
like this so instead vidit tries a
different move he plays knight the b6
check and this move works unless it
doesn't and by it it doesn't i mean if
shiro finds a beautiful refutation of
the move uh probably a vidit maybe he
saw it maybe he didn't maybe he decided
it didn't work
but feel free to pause the video here
and try to find pretty much the only
move for shirok in this position while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on doing the
unimaginable and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show of course we
just pick up the knight on b6 queen
captures on v6 that's what shirov needs
to play in order to survive this it
looks weird because well you just lost
your queen but not really after queen
captures we're going to play bishop c5
check and bring win back the queen so
queen captures knight sorry queen
captures knight captures and now let's
say f captures on e4 and uh we continue
playing this so it's a really
uh really crazy position uh however
after night the b6 check shiro did not
see queen captures on b6 or maybe he
decided that it wasn't all that great uh
he just played uh king the b8 and now
this is a problem bishop to f4 check we
have bishop to d6 and now bishop the c4
bringing more pieces into the attack as
you can see verit is getting a lot of
development in uh shiro is also getting
a lot of development in the entire board
is just very well developed uh and again
an incredibly difficult position to
calculate sheriff plays queen to e8 and
this move completely blunders the game
away uh the correct way to play this
even though it's hard to say if this
would be enough for black is e3
a crazy stuff and okay now the queen is
hanging and once we move the queen queen
b2 we attack the knight here or queen a2
then queen f5 uh what's happening here
we're attacking the bishop of course the
bishop will capture bishop with check it
comes with temple rook captures on d6
now queen captures on b3 and now this
spectacular e2 move but who who would
see such things and now after bishop
captures an e2 queen to c5 check
connecting with the knight and again we
get this position king h1 rook captures
on b6 attacks the queen queen somewhere
queen captures an f7 let's say and white
will always enjoy this uh well just this
fact that the black king is wide in the
open and the white king is safe on h1
okay the white king is not safe but it's
much much safer than the black king so
this would not be pleasant um
in any way however if he saw what was
happening after queen to e8
then he probably would have
went for that line so here vidit just
goes for bishop captures on the e6 with
check rook captures and now bishop
captures on b3 so winning the piece and
now how do you continue here well shiro
probably had plans of e captures on f3
because now it seems like the position
is just falling apart after rook comes
to g8 the problem is if e captures on f3
then there's this beautiful bishop to d5
resource and all of a sudden black has
no moves uh what do you what do you what
do you play here the only move that
comes to mind is bishop captures on b5
but that is insufficient if bishop
captures on d5 we just capture it and
we're up a piece unless black captures
that knight on d5 but after this happens
it's actually a force to check maybe in
six as the black king is wide in the
open so of course if you go here we just
capture on a6 and if you go right to the
middle of the board then we go for a
nice king hunt rook fc one checking d7
and now look at this a nice beautiful
queen to b8 checkmate
so that's the reality of it and after
bishop captures on b3 uh should have had
to waste the move uh to bring one more
attacker into the game but this is all
the time in the world that it needs to
just bring the knight back into the game
knight c4 now attacks the rook saves the
piece uh rook to d3 attacks the bishop
and just bishop c2 and now once the rook
moves we're just gonna capture on e4 and
there's nothing more to worry about so
here e captures an f3 sheet of has to
continue happily attacking hoping for
the best uh but now in a crazy position
like this it's actually a com move that
uh seals the deal and that is pawn to g3
and after this move there's really no
more moves for black rook the c3 was
played as the rook is still hanging but
not knight a5 just going after the
bishop we're interested in trades only
as now we're up material queen to e2 was
played and now just bishop captures on a
h7 and he was in this position on move
30 that alex ishiro resigned the game
and what a spectacular victory for vidit
in only 30 moves against the sicilian
defense
so here
even though it looks like there's
something happening yes the bishop is
nice the pawn on f3 is very nice but
what do you even play your rook is
hanging
after something like rook g7 we just
eliminate one of the attackers and now
whatever black plays we just don't care
96 we bring the knight into the game
black can never trade because the end
game is completely lost for black we're
up a piece and well the the the triple f
pawn does not help here uh so after
bishop captures an h7 actually resigned
and a spectacular victory forbid it in
round one
of the belgrade feeder grand prix so
this is the second uh grand prix then
we'll have the third one and then we
will finally have the two uh final
challengers not challenger but the two
final participants of the next few day
candidates tournament
uh so i remember this line well you will
probably be seeing it a lot uh in online
chess if you play the night off or if
you don't if you like playing against
the night or four if you face the night
of a lot maybe queen to d3 is something
worth looking into because as you've
seen it's an incredibly sharp idea that
can go very very wrong for black very
very quickly
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh
i would like to thank diego
enriquez uh matt back with gregory bosco
mick flannery and jorgen levdonski for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the video grand prix until
it ends uh so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day